how's it going gamers today we're
bringing out the number one gaming
animal
of all the hedgehog to prove once and
for all
that i'm a gamer we're gonna build doggy
an obstacle course apparently my
martha's already done this
but i'm doing it better that's right
marzia
[Music]
what's better i have a plan i gotta
admit
jesus you see that i almost got killed
i got on this
but this will be his central hub for now
you're gonna get a seesaw
to show that you have balance you're
gonna get a slide
to show that you have courage you're
going to get a cannon
because cannons are awesome you're going
to get a tunnel
to show you don't have beer and finally
bridge of that that's my plan at least
what do you think marcy mine's improves
the bridge of death you're hurting your
friends
usually doggy sleeps at this hour
they're uh nocturnal right is that it
yeah charge your energy you're gonna
need it doggy
this is the seesaw
[Music]
[Applause]
that's so crap oh it has the base as
well
what does it call like those tv shows
where gladiators are like
when they run a course humans do it
do you not have that in italy well
that's what doggy is you're the ultimate
battle warrior
we got the seesaw then do you think he
will go on it
yeah he's safety
he's shaking the whole thing
doggy what are you doing he's warming up
that's his stretches
okay this is weird this is really weird
it's got strength
i respect that all right for those of
you concerned about doggy safety we got
safety foams
no problem all right dougie
[Applause]
okay again no this is not for you how do
we make him go on it
what if we put you there
[Music]
come on there's millions of people
watching
all right
oh where where am i
that's my boy that's doggy right there
you see that
okay we might have to build something to
make sure he
actually goes in him right stop
all right i'll put you back in look at
that ass boy
i work out here i put my
uh bench there and then one time doggy
just put his butt
on the glass and started pooping on the
glass
it was the most he's doing the thing
again it's the most disgusting thing
i've seen because his butt looks like
his face so he looks like he was pooping
from his mouth
anyway now you know all right see song
and be complete
what's next whoa
he will definitely go through this i'm
thinking like where should we place it
i think he should like go up the sofa
and then slide down
front flip up the seesaw you know what i
mean
all right let's try this
[Music]
there's no turning back
he's so slow i thought hedgehogs were
fast
i thought that was the whole point of
hedgehog
this is not gonna work this is what
happens to our children
you don't give them obstacles they
become weak well screw the cannon
anytime
you can't do the cannon he can
definitely do it he can't do the cannon
there's no way
don't give me that look we raised a
weakling
i'm a failure as a father
bridge of that let's go i need you to
have my mm-hmm how do i do this
show me everything okay we got foam yeah
and we got more phone we got a little
house
i think this is the starting point we've
got a tunnel
mm-hmm we got some stuff
and we got decor
[Applause]
look i can go i can go in
much better than my headshot
so what did you envision i thought he
would move it
i want a bridge
i didn't plan this out i thought i
planned it out
but i didn't plan it up it's gonna be
okay am i can you go through here
[Music]
did you get it good job so he starts
there
slides down goes in the tunnel
the tunnel of death everything
yes
[Music]
okay okay
how do i make him go through this i feel
like he will definitely go if he has no
choice
listen when we got doggy the guy that
sold him was like oh you can just rock
him it's whatever
i'm not saying what do you not remember
that no no it's not good you drop them
it's okay
they just followed so people are saying
i'm too much right now
i'm not too much because we saved him
from a psychopath okay
do you understand from one psychopath to
another apparently
we wrote 10 hours for this hedgehog 15.
oh wait now we won't go up uh we need to
lead to the bridge of death
okay after the cannon it will shoot him
up right how are you gonna shoot him up
special effects i will do it then the
finale you will have to walk
oh my god
can we have some cutesy marcia all your
background
[Music]
i like that bridge of death
that's bridge of death add some fire on
explosion side
all right place your bets who thinks
bridget that
will be success
[Music]
you're not raising your hand all right
let's bring out the contestant
never whenever you feel comfortable
go through the slide of that oh he's
about to do it
do it do it doggy come on
channel your inner sonic oh oh oh
oh don't go on the sides oh yes yes yes
yes
come on slide up there slide to that
come on
but he knows he's like this is a bad
idea
he's smarter than he looks i gotta give
him that
but he's tempted to go come on come on
yes yes yes
[Music]
this is the worst slide now you're an
acrobat
well done doggy you totally earned this
oh god damn it
oh my god it's all falling apart i can't
believe
this
he's behind you he's under your legs
okay
he did the tunnel of crotch what the
hell is
the word where did you
come from we're starting the other side
cut the timer
cut the timer side cut the timer
all right start the timer three two one
start the timer
this is safe doggy trust me trust me
i've done this many times before
[Music]
oh my god slide of that whoa
record speed do you see that
replay on that side oh my god the slide
of
death the game behind him has closed
there is
no way for doggy but through
the tunnel he's going through the tunnel
ladies and gentlemen
record speed sonic is picking up super
fast where is
all this energy coming from oh he's made
it through the tunnel already
incredible now
before he passes through the tunnel he
must answer
pewdiepie riddle three questions
what is the
doggy will now go through pewdiepie
tunnel
yeah and the tunnel is shut behind doggy
it's locked
in and it looks like pewdiepie himself
is the one holding
that oh he's already through the camera
he's already going through the cabinet
this is
insane will he do it
no he won't give him time he just needs
time
it is a scary oh no that's tape he loves
sleep
he likes tape yeah dude i've seen other
hedgehogs online and they're a lot
better than you i just want to point
that out
there we go you heard the mocking
gesture can he
challenge it and he's about to whoa
good job doggy good job
all right now so i've added that so he
flies off here
here's just edit so he flies away this
guy
this is the final act because if he hits
that tambourine
he's going to win one million dollars
mr beast himself is sponsoring this
video that's right
i'm actually decided to help him oh god
i'm scared for you doggie all right
appreciate them here we go
where's your dinner
[Music]
friendship
he's going he's traversing branch of
doom oh my god
you got this man got this keep going
forward
keep going forward oh my god slider dad
oh already
incredible [ __ ] gesture
then he challenge it and he's about to
keep going forward you got this you're
so close
you were so close no
disqualification on the spy
doggy you're an amazing contestant
and you did really well okay and you're
not weak
you're just a little slob
right follow next time on ultimate
hedgehog gladiator
to see if doggie will be able to make it
through the bridge of bed
i'm your host
he's so good at climbing though all
right thanks for watching guys
bye bye hey